[Música]
é bom falar sobre o tema como vocês
viram na apresentação é só o
empreendedor e com uma maioria de vocês
acham que o empreendedorismo não é você
ter um cnpj você ser dono de um negócio
você tem um estado de espírito de
resolver o problema de criar solução de
oportunidade muitas vezes no caos e tem
a capacidade e maturidade de criar o
próprio caos pra sair da zona de
conforto
tem uma frase eu gosto muito de falar de
um sócio que ele fala que não existe
crescimento na zona de conforto e não
existe conforto na zona de crescimento
eu comecei a vender o cartão de visita
assim que entrei na faculdade era uma
forma de obter uma renda extra
logo depois eu comecei no mundo físico e
eu acompanhei exatamente essa mudança
toda do mundo digital s entrada desse
universo de startup das empresas que
antigamente demoravam 20 e 30 anos para
construir marca para crescer
de repente um ano em seis meses já eram
conhecidos em todo o brasil
não vi exatamente esse período e foi aí
que eu saí de vendedor de cartão de
visita a vendedora de loja virtual um
destaque como esse a gente sem
investimento em três anos construiu 45
mil e comerce transacionado a us 500
milhões de reais
como entramos navteq somos adquiridos
pela setecs
hoje com mais de 15 bilhões em
transações por ano e e um maior poder eu
acho o maior ganho dessa transação foi
passar a ter acesso a entender essa
mudança no consumidor porque se os
negócios estavam sendo criados e
começavam a não mais querer ter um site
sim e commerce e serviços de produto não
importava a mudança estava no consumo
a mudança estava na forma da gente
consome os produtos
enquanto muita gente quer montar um
negócio pensa nesse negócio em seu
negócio totalmente online um homem este
ano como a gente ouve falar na verdade o
consumidor ele tinha mudado e é isso que
eu quero trazer hoje aqui pra vocês eu
quero tentar mostrar algumas provocações
e aí a primeira delas a primeira
reflexão que eu queria falar exatamente
essa é a mobilidade sem sair do lugar
como hoje quando a gente não viaja no
feriado para onde estão os nossos amigos
a gente tá lá no instagram parecendo que
está vivendo aquele momento sabendo tudo
o que está acontecendo muitas vezes até
mais do que se a gente tivesse
porque a gente consegue olhar todo mundo
ao mesmo tempo o rock in rio alguns dias
e ouviu os meus amigos e ano e eu não
posso que não podia e eu tinha a mesma
sensação de estar conseguindo viver um
pouco daquilo então não é só o poder da
compra online mas o poder de viver
experiências muitas vezes sem sair do
lugar
e tudo isso começou com a internet a
internet proporcionou essa mudança só
que antigamente não era uma mobilidade
100% como é hoje
antigamente a gente tinha que fazer para
poder ver um vídeo pra poder entrar um
blog
a gente muitas vezes em que saiu da sala
e no quartinho do computador ou no lugar
da casa onde ficava o computador sentar
na cadeira e ficar mexendo no computador
navegando nos blogs de turismo
tentando ficar nos chats nas redes
sociais da época o orkut já falecido cut
ea gente ficava lá acompanhando a vida
dos outros conseguindo viver um pouco
pela vida dos outros vendo o vídeo e ali
começava um pouco essa disrupção na
questão de mobilidade
depois veio o smartphone vem o celular
ou celular mudou totalmente o jogo
porque a internet ela estava ali
embarcada no celular
a gente simplesmente estava no cinema
vendo o instagram que estava acontecendo
respondendo em meio a gente estava em
casa navegando no shopping e aí a
mudança fui completa
a gente parou de comprar as coisas por
impulso e começou a ver depoimentos
havia informações haver comparativos
isso mudou completamente a forma o funil
de compras decisão de compra jornada de
um consumidor começou a ser totalmente
transformado e não adiantava mais você
tem o melhor ponto do shopping
você tinha que ter conteúdo do seu
produto você tem informação você tinha
que ter comparativo você tinha que dar
informação ao seu usuário ao seu cliente
pra você poder ter no jogo e aí eu trago
uma reflexão sobre o banco digital
será que em algum momento a gente
imaginou os bancos que a gente mais
gosta não tem uma agência
eu me lembro que assim que eu tinha eu
fiz 18 anos e outro uma conta no banco
uma poupança e cara era banco do lado da
minha casa tinha que ser o banco do lado
da minha casa
na minha casa hoje em dia a gente muitas
vezes nem sabe aonde fica filial do
banco que a gente mais utiliza e que a
gente confia em deixar o nosso dinheiro
então o valor de tempo o valor de lugar
mudou completamente
a gente pode estar aqui mas vocês podem
estar no celular olhando a história de
vocês se o assunto for relevante e eu
não conseguir ter a atenção de vocês
necessária que é o que acontece com a
televisão à televisão ela tem audiência
mas ela não tem mais a nossa atenção ela
distribui conteúdo mas a gente está ali
sentado navegando no celular venda e
meio e praticamente ouvindo o que ela
está transmitindo pra gente
a rádio por exemplo já não quando está
ouvindo uma rádio que está realmente
prestando atenção porque a gente está
sempre fazendo alguma coisa quando está
ouvindo que muitas vezes não é mexer no
telefone e para pensar como é muito
louco isso né
hoje em dia a gente quiser comprar no
shopping mais luxuoso da china a gente
navega por ele simplesmente sem sair de
casa você pode estar uma comunidade do
rio de janeiro que você vai conseguir
comprar o shopping mais luxuoso da china
então foi uma decepção para a gente hoje
o que é a mobilidade
será que a gente precisa estar
presencialmente para conseguir fazer
algo para conseguir conhecer algo está
em algum lugar e quando a gente analisa
isso a fundo a gente vê o quanto a gente
está caminhando para uma era em tandil o
que a gente dá mais valor hoje são
coisas intangíveis
quando a gente começa a olhar as
empresas mais valiosas do mundo no top
a gente já via a maioria delas sem
produto sem serviço a maioria dessas
empresas elas constroem ecossistema elas
criam marca constrói a comunidade
mas quem acaba entregando que elas
vendem são outras pessoas
as outras empresas antigamente ter
sucesso para você chegar na sua festa de
final de ano falar com a sua família e
você falar que estava com 100
funcionários com 10 lojas físicas com um
milhão de reais em estoque e as pessoas
falavam nosso
está com muito sucesso você tá crescendo
você está prosperando
quando você olha hoje o que é ter
sucesso você vender direto da fábrica
vem de outro país vêm da china
é você ter menos pessoas trabalhando pra
você a gente reconhece mais as empresas
e os gestores que tem menos pessoas
trabalhando que são mais eficientes que
usam a tecnologia é mais poderoso hoje
você cria a audiência que você não
consegue tocar nessa audiência
diferente de um dia histórico você tem
um milhão de seguidores do instagram
você tem um milhão de listas de email
você tem um milhão de pessoas
interessadas no seu conteúdo que te dão
realmente a atenção é a grande briga do
shopping onde o shopping ele por muito
tempo para um lugar onde a gente
precisava está para encontrar as coisas
para conhecer as coisas mas o cliente
nunca foi do shopping o cliente sempre
foi da marca sempre foi da loja
e é exatamente essa briga que a gente
está vendo hoje que o maior valor que a
gente tem hoje é na audiência é na
autoridade na reputação é no nível de
atenção que a nossa marca o nosso
negócio consegue ter o nosso usuário do
nosso cliente
este incidente é um cara que é homem
consumidor hoje nos tornamos o homem
consumidor não só os nossos negócios que
precisam nascer multicanal
nós nos tornamos multi muitos
consumidores
a gente que está em casa vendo a novela
ver uma jóia de uma camisa e uma roupa
de um imóvel na mesma hora a gente entre
compra
na mesma hora a gente entra para saber
mais informação e quando a gente fala
sobre isso quando a gente tá shopping
a gente encontra o que a gente quer mas
a gente pesquisa no telefone e às vezes
e compra online que você está presente
no lugar tomando ação em outro lugar e
as gerações que muitas pessoas falam pra
mim é um frango mas isso é uma geração
muito específica
quem realmente faz dessa forma é a
pessoa de 25 a 35 anos que compra pela
internet usa a internet
na verdade não é há dois anos atrás eu
me lembro de na casa dos meus pais para
jantar e eu lembro muito bem que meu pai
me chamava de ali amado
ficar no telefone a minha mãe pedia o
tempo inteiro pra eu sair do telefone
hoje em dia eu vou na casa dos meus pais
que têm seus sessenta e poucos anos
ambos estão no telefone a minha mãe não
sai do instagram nesta grande mãe é uma
coisa de louco ela segue dois ex
namorada ea família e ela amarra tudo
que ela vendo o instagram podia ela
escreveu na minha foto curtir
eu falei mãe que o vila não curtia foto
não é só dar dois toques na tela
o meu pai que me chamava de alienado de
um telefone né
é um smartphone até algum tempo atrás
agora fica lá no batizado passando
corrente o dia inteiro pra mim durante
jantar com aquela fonte tamanho 10 que
você tá vendo que ele está fazendo
do outro lado da mesa o meu sobrinho de
cinco anos
a gente só consegue manter like é tu
dando um telefone ou um tablet para ele
e não basta só dar o telefone o tablet
porque se você não der um cartão ele não
passa de fase no jogo quem tem sobrinho
sabe como é que é do dia minha
secretária chegou pro sofredo tem 300
dólares aqui do google play o que é isso
ela não sei ver com o seu sobrinho
porque ele usa o telefone eu cheguei
para ele e falei que o bce comprou
alguma coisa no meu cartão no jogo ele
olhou pra mim e falou eu serei o jogo eu
falei pô minha conta né
a minha avó que tem seus 95 anos
hoje em dia faz quase tudo pelo telefone
3g o primo até tirou dodô whatsapp o
texto e botou stick e aí eu tava vendo
minha voz do grupo da família como se
comunicando por esticão e ela botou
expectativas foram criadas
agora a gente está vivendo uma nova era
então não tem mais idade para tecnologia
influenciar não tem mais idade para
tecnologia ser um meio para alguma coisa
para a tecnologia resolver a 1 e as
empresas estão usando a tecnologia para
criar a comunidade para construir tribos
porque nós seres humanos temos esse
comportamento
a gente começa a estudar o ser humano a
gente começa a perceber que a gente
procura
com pessoas igual a gente com pessoas
parecidas da mesma classe social dos
mesmos gostos com as mesmas habilidades
então as empresas perceberam isso e as
empresas que estão construindo hoje
fazendo diferente elas não vendem mais
produto serviço porque o produto serviço
hoje em quase todos os mercados de
commodities
elas estão construindo marca com sua
atenção e criando comunidade porque
através do relacionamento que se
aumentar as vendas e não através de você
ter a melhor oferta porque a melhor
oferta
cada dia que passa fica mais curto fica
mais rápido então nessa luta nessa
guerra da audiência versus a atenção é
que se criou um novo procedimento novo
protocolo que permite a gente criar uma
marca no interior do rio de janeiro e
ser uma das maiores empresas dos estados
unidos
a gente pode ter uma marca como creche
tech da tijuca ea gente com isto
conseguiu ser uma das cinco maiores
plataformas no brasil a internet ela
quebrou barreiras ela quebrou aquela
relação de tempo espaço
a gente sempre teve e ela permitiu a
gente tem mobilidade para mudar o nosso
negócio para mudar a nossa direção para
mudar o foco da nossa vida em foco que é
uma das habilidades que eu considero
mais importante hoje no ser humano
e quando se fala de mobilidade quando a
gente está fazendo uma viagem se a gente
não tiver um foco de project comece onde
a gente vai chegar a gente acaba levando
10 horas em uma viagem que poderia ser
em duas então na vida profissional na
nossa vida que eu acredito ser uma coisa
muito único é make híbrido isso a gente
vê muita propaganda vejo muita gente
falando de separar a vida profissional
da vida pessoal mas eu vejo como uma
coisa só
a gente tem que trabalhar para criar
sinergia entre essas duas coisas a gente
tem muito esse poder e um novo
comportamento de compra e se a gente
cada vez mais usando a internet é a
gente cada vez mais vivendo experiências
em outros lugares no dia do rock in rio
eu percebi uma coisa que eu fiquei muito
impressionado
eu percebi que naquele momento tinha
mais celular ligado fazendo live do rock
in rio do que a audiência de tv
conseqüentemente tinham mais pessoas
vivendo aquele momento através de
celulares dos outros do que através da
televisão
então isso é muito subjetivo isso muda
demais e eu pensei estudando um novo
comportamento do consumidor que tem
quatro coisas que a gente não abre mão
de comprar as coisas de consumir amor
tempo medo e dinheiro e tudo que a gente
apaixonada a gente compra sem pensar
tudo que gera ganho pra gente que a
gente está sentindo que está ganhando
alguma coisa a gente compra sem pensar
em tudo aquilo que combate o nosso medo
que vai acabar o que vai gerar mais
saúde
a gente compra sem pensar em tudo aquilo
que a gente compra que pode gerar um
minuto a mais de dois minutos a mais que
a gente pode fazer as coisas mais rápido
a gente também compra muito menos
consultar na internet muito mais rápido
muito mais por impulso
agora aqueles produtos que a gente
compra por impulso durante a vida
inteira
a gente vai um reclame aqui a gente vai
ver comentário a gente joga no grupo
batizado de comprar pergunta com um
amigo
então a gente precisa construir uma
empresa que crie relacionamento com o
cliente e que a gente entenda que hoje
não importa onde o escritório não
importa o objeto empresa não importa o
produto ou serviço que você vende a
audiência ea capacidade de você
conseguir construir um amor que você
conseguir criar um negócio ganha ganha
que você combater alguma coisa que
aquela pessoa tem medo que é um problema
então o foco do negócio hoje é o cliente
é resolver algum problema do cliente
você vai conseguir construir um negócio
exponencial e não vai interessar onde
está mas sim para onde está construindo
para onde você está indo ea nossa
geração foi abençoada com esse poder com
esse recurso chamado mobilidade
eu queria dizer pra finalizar hoje com
vocês é um prazer imenso estar aqui a
agradecer pelo convite e dizer como
última mensagem que na minha visão a
gente não está tendo um mundo sendo
mudada através da tecnologia mas a gente
está vivendo a tecnologia mudando o
mundo então a tecnologia não é o fim
a tecnologia não é sua concorrente a
tecnologia um meio
pra gente fazer as coisas de forma
diferente então o que eu peço pra vocês
saí daqui pensando refletindo e talvez
fazendo a gente valorizar a experiência
valorizar o momento é importante a gente
está junto com a pessoa que está junto
com nosso país está junto com a nossa
mãe mas uma ligação através de live um
contato 11 a disappear de um valor hoje
quase como dar um abraço ea gente só tem
que se fazer presente usando a
tecnologia e fazendo a mobilidade sem
cortar cada vez mais
[Aplausos]
[Música]